this week on quad Riga Afghanistan a
lost cause Germany's bundeswehr troops
are pulling out of the northern Afghan
province of Kunduz almost all NATO
forces are due to leave afghanistan by
the end of 2014 the Afghan army will
have the responsibility of dealing with
the Taliban insurgency on its own the
government will have to maintain the
gains made in development and human
rights since 2001 but there is a huge
question mark over whether it will be
able to do that the government of
President Hamid Karzai is widely
perceived as corrupt its army is weak
our foreign troops leaving too soon
what's next for the country peace or
more war your host this week Ali as lon
hello and welcome to quadriga
Afghanistan's football and cricket teams
are producing extraordinarily positive
results but unfortunately the same
cannot be said of the political
situation in the country which still
remains very much fragile so the
question is with the international
mission set to end by the end of 2014
where is the country headed and that is
exactly what we will ask and discuss on
today show together with three experts
who've been following events in
Afghanistan very closely welcome to
malai stout who is a political analyst
from Afghanistan based in Berlin he is
also the founder of the Afghan youth
foundation for unity and served
previously as the chief of staff of the
transition coordination Commission in
Afghanistan Robert Reid is the bureau
chief for The Associated Press in
Germany previously he was based in Kabul
where he served as the APS news director
for Afghanistan and Pakistan and Coggan
chetla is a freelance journalist with a
focus on Afghanistan a country she has
visited several times she also serves as
the regional coordinator for Afghanistan
at the Deutsche Welle Academy where
she's organizing media development
projects in Afghanistan welcome to the
show malish opened out now the
II US troops are set to leave by the end
of 2014 that is at least what President
Obama has promised and pledged to the
American people is that a move too early
too soon but first of all we have to be
clear these are combat troops you are
talking about and we still have the
negotiations over the bilateral security
agreement going on and as far as I'm
aware and now deputy minister of foreign
affairs said few days ago that it's just
weeks away and President Karzai has
revealed that there could be nine
military bases of the years post-2014 on
the question whether or not it's too
early I had my doubts two years ago when
I used to work for the transition
coordination commission but now looking
at the way the Afghans switch the Afghan
government has responded and ask you to
forces in particular it seems to be the
right move what we need is according to
our former intelligence agency had a
proper relationship with the world
specially the US their peasants and no
longer counts because our security
forces have basically shown in the past
few months that they're pretty much
capable of taking over the security of
course it's fragile of course there are
spaces that are contested of course
there's desertion from the Army and the
police but still the progress has been
remarkable given the fact that the focus
on our secret forces only happened in
2008-2009 Robert reads malas doubt says
the withdrawal is the right move would
you agree i think the withdrawal is the
is the obvious move at this point first
of all i don't think you ever get to a
situation where the time to leave is
right that's that's just not going to
happen it's like a lot of things in life
you know you hear you know in 30 40
years ago people used to say in the
United States you know the time is not
right for racial integration well it
happened you know they adapted
politically there's no support in the
United States for maintaining this
mission in Afghanistan is gonna be hard
enough to keep seven to eight thousand
America
troops there anyway and so I think at
this point it's a situation where all
sides have done all that they reasonably
can do to prepare for this move and now
it's just basically up to the Afghans I
might point out that you know there are
lessons that should be taken from the
Soviet experience in Afghanistan and one
of those is withdrawal doesn't
necessarily have to mean abandonment I
mean I think what what sank Najibullah
is government as much as anything as the
collapse of the Soviet Union and the
lack of funding you know their army was
doing respectable in the field but if if
if withdrawal does not meet abandonment
then there is a chance that this will
succeed Carlene and shayla you just
returned from Afghanistan you spent some
some time there what is the mood on the
ground when you talk to the average
Afghan people on the street what is the
mood these days yeah i think it is
actually quite interesting because i
think what you said that there is not
enough support in our countries to
continue this mission is basically
because people here really don't know
what afghan think about it and how
thankful they are for what development
workers have done and also how the
military has supported them so what i
have seen during my visits there is that
people especially in the north are very
very thankful i always mention prestige
objects like infrastructural help with
the new airport with a new teacher
learning center that hasn't existed
before and also just of your things like
bridges streets and so so i think people
see that and they also see the little
things that we do and that little
development organizations to and yeah
and it's always surprising to people
here it is very surprising everything
yeah thanks oh really I didn't think so
because of course the images they get
from Afghanistan are quite different and
they cannot really interpret them well
but aside from being thankful is there
also a sense of anxiety
with the date of 2014 with the
withdrawal looming well I've seen both
I've seen eggs I anxiety on the one hand
that people are afraid what might happen
a lot of right especially those who have
helped us a lot to have set things in
the last year's it might not be very
popular in the next time if there is a
transition and power but on the other
hand I've also seen people who said yeah
we are kind of ready to take more
responsibility now and we have to do
that also so there is l so just this
sense of people that they it's their job
and we can't all be there forever but I
think that is just true for some of the
things we're doing there but of course
in many many fields they still need help
and I'm really hoping that the Civil
help we are giving to Afghanistan will
continue to be there and for a long time
not only short time projects that will
not be sustainable analyzed out the
Afghan people are ready to take on more
responsibilities as Calvin shade light
and indeed they will have to the Afghan
army for instance is already in charge
of security control of the country do
you think they're up for the task well I
pretty much think so as Robert said
before like the Army in the past and
when they were capable of basically
continue to save the state and only the
funding was cut off from the Silva tea
and then the collapse happened it's
still the case I mean we need around
about four billion dollars a year for
our military support and if dad keeps
trickling in I think the Army and the
police are pretty much capable of
defeating the knot I mean they can
create a long haul you know they can
create a deadlock for a long time and
that will basically we're out the
insurgency in the terrorists because the
they're encouraging signs the right now
they are conducting an operation as a
district of Logan and it went pretty
well you know the but of course there
are lots of issues too so you cannot
ignore them lots of issues which we will
discuss a force on today show Robert
Reid there is a question some people are
wondering namely if the average Afghan
is better
off now than he or she was before two
thousand one before the onset mission
started to Afghanistan you've been to
Afghanistan many times you've lived
there you covered Afghanistan
extensively what what is your sense I
think they're better off than they were
in the Taliban times I didn't get better
off in the urban areas than they were
during the Civil War certainly i think
but i think you know problem we're
talking about Afghanistan is we use this
word Afghanistan there are many
Afghanistan's and there you know and
public perceptions and situations can
vary dramatically from you know from
place to place if you ask you know a
middle-class Afghan and Kabul is he
worried about the troops leaving him and
he's Frank your Papa tell you yes if you
talked to some guy in ponds why he's
probably happy that they're leaving it
just it varies quite a bit and I think
this is part of the challenge in
Afghanistan you know to bring this
disparate country you know together into
some sort of cohesive unit and I think
it's going to take a lot of its going to
challenge the statecraft of a lot of
Afghan leaders in the coming years and
Colleen Sheila Robert Reed has just
exemplify the intricacies and the
complexities of this country called
Afghanistan do we in the so-called West
properly understand the country even 12
years after the mission started you've
been there many times do you think we
have a good grasp of the country and its
complex setup well in general I would
say we don't because of course what we
hear from Afghanistan is very very
limited and one example for me is there
working women in Afghanistan where I
have seen women who are of course also
worried that we're leaving because they
are now in a much better situation than
they used to be yeah but that are women
that are not perceived here at all so
and also you know that we we look a lot
about how things look for example that
the burqa has not gone away so you still
see all those pictures with women
wearing the burqa but when you look a
little bit more on the details you see
women just maybe pulling it all
for a while or not wearing it in the car
or things like that there may be that
are little things but you see that there
is a sense of a little bit more Liberty
and I think that's also important you
know not only the big big big
achievements but the little things where
people feel they can dress a bit more
freely for example I also women in the
North who only wear a scarf and only
until here you know like we know it from
India yeah so that's positive things
that I see and I think we shouldn't
forget about those developments as well
as an Afghan living in Berlin my eyes
doubt do you think we in the West have a
superficial perception of your country
of Afghanistan well the media does and
it's understandable because people tend
to I mean not really try to understand
everything about the country but there
are some foreigners who have lived in
the country for a long time they have a
good level of understanding of the
country but to be honest this question
even if you posit an Afghan like me I've
lived there all my life you know it's a
difficult one to answer I would not know
every corner of the country there are so
many complexities that I would also not
know fully about so it's only a question
of having a good sense of what is going
on and then building upon that and
basically then sorting our sorting out
the whole situation but even as an
Afghani you cannot claim you know
everything about the country Robert
Horry this mission of course started in
the immediate aftermath of 9-11 it was
led by the United States to root out al
Qaeda out of Afghanistan and to take
revenge if you will now al Qaeda many
people would argue is no longer a force
in Afghanistan itself but they've moved
elsewhere they've moved to Mali and
other countries in the Middle East do
you think this problem has been solved
adjust just been shifted away
geographically speaking no I don't think
been solved I don't think he's been
solved because the wrong tools were used
to you know to combat it although I
personally have sympathy for the US
administration in deciding to you know
use a military option in Afghanistan you
know given the realities of you know two
plus thousand dead in the United States
but
no at some point the you know the whole
thing morph get it changed from a
mission that was you know defeat Al
Qaeda to one that was supposed to
reinforce the government and therefore
inherently morph began the one to oppose
the government's enemies which you know
with the resurgent Taliban and now we
have a situation where even if you
accept a White House arguments that
they're fewer than 100 full-time al
Qaeda operatives in in Afghanistan it's
irrelevant it's just a name you have you
know hostile political Islam operating
in Afghanistan and in Pakistan and Yemen
and in parts of Tunisia and a whole
range of countries have no the problem
has has shifted its it's like it's like
trying to pick up a ball of mercury so
there's a lack of strategy than if you
if I understand it correctly there's
been a lack of strategy on the part of
the US and the I submission yeah I think
well I think the ICF mission was to do a
particular job and they did it but I
think broadly speaking the Americans
have had trouble in coming up with a
strategy to deal with al-qaeda as an
idea and as a political movement that
transcends national borders I don't
think that's a secret isn't it also
because al Qaeda itself has transformed
so much it's so strategizing against a
force that has been modifying itself is
not easy yeah that's true i mean it's
like you know treating a disease that
you know morphs becomes resistant to
vaccines although i think in a way you
know part of this is a I don't know
whether part of it might be that we
never have fully understood what
al-qaeda was even in 1996 you know and I
hear people talk about all the luck i
just changed with the very word you know
it means the base you know i like to
think of old al Qaeda in a way like a an
investment bank where people came up
with ideas be they ideas in the Hamburg
cell to go you know to launch an air
attack in the United States and
something else like this and they went
to al-qaeda to you know like a an
entrepreneur does to a bank
I have an idea I need your support they
got the support that's quite different
from a highly structured western-style
party that conceives ideas and projects
and sees them through and I don't think
this difference has ever been fully
grasp and appreciated so therefore he
actually has been I mean I'm sorry I'm
kind of golf here because the general
mcchrystal is a former commander of i
surf he has done after he to type he did
a nautical where he basically said that
we were fighting against some network
and we had to become a network actually
to be able to tackle the problem I you
know that's general McChrystal the
problem is I don't think even that idea
has been sold entirely to the public's
and the ruling establishments in the
West Country that ruling out the al
Qaeda out of Afghanistan is one thing
the Taliban however is still very much
there with the Taliban of course ruled
Afghanistan from 96 to 2001 until it was
routed out by us and foreign troops do
you feel the sense on the part of
Afghans that they fear the return of the
Taliban once foreign troops have left
Afghanistan yes they absolutely do but
just on the al Qaeda part i would like
to mention that i really don't think
that this problem can be solved either
by becoming a network or in military
ways because how we as we see how they
went to the how they were even able to
get to the north of pakistanis because
of course people are not educated the
media are either non-existent in some
areas or only show one view so there are
illegal channels and there is there's a
lot of misdirected information so i
think in this situation we have to go to
the root of the problem and not just try
to fight and walk behind al-qaeda from
country one country to the next we have
to work on the roots we have to work in
education we have to work on having
diverse media everywhere in the world I
mean of course now I'm saying that
because it's my job also but I think
really it would be a solution to the
problem and about your question on the
Taliban people are very much afraid
especially those people who were in the
country during that time even those who
who went to other countries and came
back later because of what they've seen
I mean especially in smaller places
where there were really horrible things
the Taliban have done or also about
especially women and all some working
women in Kabul who have practically
hidden during that whole time and not
gone out and I mean I see what kind of
personalities they have and how hard it
must have been for them to go through it
especially not knowing if it will ever
end so of course they are very very
worried to lose their position to lose
their ability to work to be in society
and not only about women also about men
about everyone who likes to speak their
mind who likes to work it to live a free
life it is a horrible thought but they
are not convinced that they will come
back I think there is a big sense that
that that can be avoided somehow through
well not only for an Afghan army but
also through a smaller militias that
will probably come up so I think people
are not not necessarily convinced that
they will come back especially not to
power and especially not to Kabul my
lies out there is a sentiment that the
return of the Taliban is inevitable
though once foreign troops leave what's
your take on that I don't know where
that senses to be honestly the best
problem well if you look at Taliban is
another Taliban itself has numerous
times announced and proclaimed that they
are going to to make an attempt to come
back and take over control of the
country hasn't they yeah but they've
also engaged in the political process
and they've also pronounced publicly
that we cannot assume that we'll be back
in power as forcefully as in the past
you cannot assume that we'll have the
authority we had in the red of the state
that they created and they've also
publicly been they've been cracks within
the Taliban movement you know as an
organization other people who are saying
it cannot continue the way we have done
it we have to basically come around with
other groups in the country and
become part of the polity you know
they've they've said that and they're on
record so I don't see them as returning
the force and basically the sweeping
across the country and then creating
their own mr8 that's not going to happen
they will have to talk to the Afghan
government and Afghan state is in a much
better position than it was previously
the democratic space that has been
created as the freedom of speech at the
media is booming you know so there is a
very close scrutiny of what is going on
and it's the the other thing that maybe
goes it slips under the door and there
are so many things that happen the the
leadership in the country now the
political leadership the elite it's it's
a different situation for them and they
don't want to lose the prestige that
they've had for the past 12 years so
they'll fight on so what are you saying
there's a new Taliban Taliban two point
oh if you will a more softer more
lenient about there are different groups
within Taliban their field commanders
who are very radical door saying we're
going to continue to fight but they're
also Taliban who were political savvy
politically savvy and they know that
it's not gonna last long the point is is
Pakistan going to be cooperating because
Pakistan is the key to the Afghan issue
because Taliban to be honest I mean I
would claim this with some with some
emphasis that but Taliban would collapse
within three months once Paxton's stop
supporting it and the Pakistanis are not
going to do that because we know that
the Taliban have an al Qaeda itself it
has basically captured Pakistani state
you know the Pakistani state is hosted
to them there's a pakistani journalist
much i thought was killed by a sign in
2008 i guess he did a brilliant vote on
this how the al-qaeda members were
arrested from within the Pakistani army
and how al Qaeda new there every
location they moved and finally
basically they attacked one of the
biggest bases and impacts on here on
base and they knew how to get in how to
get out so it's the whole machinery of
paxton that is behind Taliban would you
rira betrayed the solution to the
Taliban phenomenon
problem lies not in Afghanistan itself
but in Pakistan basically yes I mean I
think you know I was thinking when I was
listening to my colleagues discuss this
here there are a couple of things that
are different the last time you know
then then were the last time the Taliban
you know came into power one a lot of
people in the urban areas welcome to the
Taliban before because they were so fed
up with the Civil War the you know the
constant threats to life and limb being
robbed at checkpoints you know
everything that went on with life in the
country that had descended into chaos
and Civil War the Taliban was seen as
you know is people who I know would
restore some semblance of order and deal
with people on a decent level that
illusion will be you know not be around
this time the other thing is Pakistan
and it'll be interesting to see how the
Pakistanis play this because one thing
that's different for Pakistan before is
Pakistan now threat it faces a jihadi
threat that they did not face in the
past you know ever since the you know
the attack on the you know in red mosque
in Islamabad and what 2007 there is an
element you know in the jihadi movement
in Pakistan that has declared war in the
Pakistani state there may be people in
Pakistan who may have second thoughts
about just opening up the Treasury and
the political largesse to the Taliban as
the you know had done before so I don't
have an answer for that but I think that
definitely will influence the way
Pakistan responds in kaavalan shayla the
United States more or less has seems to
have an acknowledged that the Taliban is
here and here to stay by engaging in
political dialogue with them in Doha
Qatar and other talks have not been
completed also due to President Karzai's
protests if you will but do you think
there was a right move on the part of
the u.s. to to engage with the Taliban
instead of ignoring them you know it is
very ironic for me how the discussion in
Pakistan is going in how did
discussion about Afghanistan is going
because in Pakistan there is really a
big uproar when people talk about
talking to the Taliban really thinking
that we have some common ground with
them or could get some achievement by by
talking to them I mean the only thing I
can I base I personally think the only
thing you can do is to split some
territory to give them some space and
have some space by on your own but to
politically find some common ground with
them where you could agree on some
common rules or common understanding i
think that in my personal opinion it is
an illusion but on the other hand i see
of course how some political leaders
think that we have to include them
because they are a big force and until
they are in the system um yeah there has
to be some exchange of information of
course but to really include them i
think is frightening people as much as
well admit maybe as much but also very
much then as coming them to power i
think because of course women for
example they fear okay if there is some
negotiation with the Taliban what will
they be compromising about is it us is
it alright and so I think it's a very
dangerous process and one person who
very much felt excluded from the talks
with the Taliban is President Karzai
allies doubts very enigmatic figure
isn't he a lot of people even see him
not as the solution but the problem that
plagues Afghanistan today as an Afghan
would you agree that President Karzai is
not really i mean i have had my own
criticism of our president but if you
look at our history in another recent
past the kind of heads of states that
we've had his head and shoulders above
anything that we've had in the past i
mean this is a guy who sometimes says
things but don't doesn't really mean
them for example when it comes to media
and freedom of media he's agreed with
the urban Amish aura several times you
know we will do this this and that but
then practically he never basically puts
strong chicks on our media when it comes
to this particular case he was dead
right about it you know because it was a
pakistani flood the way it played out in
doha and Taliban basically declaring
their own state there it was totally
wrong
Americans got it very wrong and they
accepted that and President Karzai had
the backing of the population saying
then who are we if that's the state so
he was dead right about it and to be
honest he's done so much work now when
it comes to a political settlement in
the conciliation that he knows all the
the issues in and out and dalla the
point is that a Taliban you said that
the people are afraid that they are
going to have little countries they have
their own small fiefdom that's not going
to happen they're taught the Taliban
leaders were basically saying we are
going to become part of the system like
girls education is something that every
Taliban member says yeah that's
something we have to agree to we cannot
continue like that and there's so many
former Taliban members their ex foreign
minister their ambassador in Pakistan
they now sit in Kabul in Kandahar you
know they are part of the political
process they run for Parliament so if
you look at the Taliban you know they're
as I said there are pragmatic
politicians and as soon as they see a
shot they can have a shorter power
they'll just go for it and it's not just
a Taliban that is perceived as pragmatic
but also President Karzai who whether or
not you believe he was a problem or a
solution will end this term by next year
because the elections are coming up in
afghanistan in april and let's have a
quick look at the challengers who stand
for election dozens of candidates took
part in the last presidential election
the number in next year's vote is
expected to be less former Afghan
foreign minister abdullah abdullah has
put himself forward he ran in the 2009
election and lost to President Karzai
the present foreign minister saw my
Rasool has also considered a next
possible President Rasool is not openly
committed to any of the major political
coalition's in Afghanistan observers say
Abdul Rasool sia also has good chances
of becoming president he fought the
Russians in the 1980s and has close
links to Islamist groups the last
presidential elections were marred by
allegations of fraud the question now is
whether they'll be more transparent and
fair this time while my lies doubt you
just saw who's running for election to
60 President Karzai anyone you like it's
not about my liking i guess well you're
not gone so at the end of the day it is
a matter of whether you're like one of
them or not do you think one of them can
lead Afghanistan into a more hopeful
future well it's hopeful because there
are so many checks and balances in place
now so they cannot have just a free ride
basically that's the good point about it
of course I'm happy there's a coalition
between the very forces that thought in
our urban centers in nineteen early
1990s Abdullah Abdullah's animators from
Hezbollah me and the second one is from
the way that Islam is basically these
are the parties fighting each other now
they're running on the same ticket so
that's a very positive move I don't have
particular distaste for any of them and
it's not about particle liking but i
guess the continuity will be there
they've all been saying the same thing
we'd like that the continuity to be
there but we would reform slowly so
that's important Robert ray doesn't even
matter who's going to become president
of coniston because as you've pointed
out the complexities of the country with
war loads perhaps wielding more
influence than any president could ever
do any tribal leader yielding more
influence than any president could could
possibly ever do yeah but I don't think
that means the position is irrelevant
you know for one thing someone who has
the ability or the wherewithal to
negotiate these various modus vivendi
'he's you know with regional leaders
and also I think you know what they may
need in the short term anyway is
basically a present if we can talk to
the foreign community they're really
gonna need that you know me as I've said
before you know what caused the collapse
of Najibullah government after the
Soviets withdrew as much as anything was
the collapse of the Soviet Union and the
support that they provided you know
nationalist feelings aside Afghanistan
really needs the west and in the coming
years and they need a president who can
talk to Westerners Karzai's problem cars
I can talk at one level to Westerners
but as my colleague said he's got a
tendency to flare off at the mouth you
know if you know him if you know
anything about him you know this is just
talk I'm going to join the Taliban if
the Americans do this is that no one
takes that seriously blade makes a big
impact outside the country people don't
get the joke outside the country and you
know they need a president who you know
can sell himself to the major donor
countries while at the same time you
know maintaining enough of a sense of
authority in Afghanistan he just doesn't
look like a foreign puppet car and
shayla barring unforeseen events the
election is supposed to take place next
April is this something that the the
people on the streets are talking about
is this something that is already
rolling up the interest of the average
I've gone on the street but in my
observation not so much but of course
the people I'm talking to mostly
journalists and intellectuals they are
talking about it already a lot and I
think that the sense that an
ex-president should be someone who
staying calm in critical situations
isn't the most basic one because I well
you mentioned something in our so I
think with as fragile as the whole
region is and there are some also little
flight of Pakistan about little area so
I think it is very important that
especially when one country comes on
with a strong rhetoric that you don't
shoot back with
with harsh words immediately and I think
that is most important also for people
someone they can yeah they can have some
they sing that will stay calm in
critical situations I think that is
that's most basic yeah and I think of
course they need someone who is a
diplomat as well as you mentioned with
all the provinces with powerful people
in their powerful political leaders who
also are demanding their well they are
part of the of the cake I think you will
really have to be able to balance that
power somehow and the Taliban malas
doubt have already said they will not
participate in this election in April
body mega this doesn't matter do you
think that the democratic process is
weakened as a result it doesn't matter
when it comes to process and the
long-term achievement the country is
going to have of course it does matter
when they bore people from it going to
polls you know the security may not be
as good as if Taliban have had
cooperated but there's a lot of irony oz
in this country like the Taliban members
actively collected registration cards
for different companies right now in
exchange for money sometimes in exchange
for loyalty and stuff like that so it's
not that black and white there's a lot
of gray area there and I'm sure some of
the former Taliban members are going to
run for the because we also have the
elections for our provincial councils so
they are going to run for those they
would also back particular candidates
for the presidency because they also
have a lot of tribal affiliations with
some of the people because it's not only
a war of two ideologies Islamists
against basically democratic forces it's
also a lot of different types of each
other they were jockeying for power and
that will all be played out in the
selection Robert read all of you today
on Today Show have more or less
evaluated the ICF mission and the the
foreign troops present in Afghanistan as
a positive thing looking back if you if
we evaluate the 12 years all of you more
or less have said it was with all the
shortcomings involved a good thing but
if you had to
really boil it down to the more concrete
facts what has this mission accomplished
12 years after well I think it has given
it has given Afghanistan a structure it
has had limited security success in
different parts of the country to allow
the development of institutions it has
provided a degree of hope to
particularly the urban populations to
women to other groups that felt
disenfranchised under the Taliban and
you know it he gave a chance I think you
know again it's no secret it's no great
insight it was an under resource mission
the Americans there was the vision
within the United States government
about whether even to have a mission in
Afghanistan you know just in you know
the thing and leave there was drama
about whether I staff would only be
limited to Kabul if you remember you
know expanded out of outside the country
it you know it was the stepchild of the
Bush administration and it never read by
the time attention and focus and
resources were made available the
political support was gone and Colleen
Sheila then on the opposite side what do
people and Afghanistan criticize about
the mission when you talk about them
well what is it that they say no at the
end of the day after 12 years were not
satisfied because well you know honestly
before i came to afghanistan for the
first time i would have thought that
they were much more critical of war
crimes and things like that and of
course there are people who speak out
about that very intensely but in general
overall the whole conversations you have
it's not that much of an issue and i
think that is probably also our view
that here we see it as a really big
problem when some soldiers died but
there they are kind of used to conflict
for a long time so it is not something
very up north
happening and but I think that we are so
what we don't see here is that it is
more complex than just Taliban against
military now but there are other groups
rivalries arrival T's in the provinces
that are very important that might else
will break out again if the foreign
troops are not anymore at one place or
the other I mean it's some places it is
not that relevant but at others it might
make a difference and so we might have a
difficult situation but on the other
hand I think people you prepared for
that we forget I'm talking about the
insurgency is it's not just the Taliban
people in the West tend to give Talib
used to turn pal of mine as a broad
brush for everybody who's got a beef
against the government you know there's
the Islam Islamic google Uzbekistan
their factions of his biz la me is the
hi Connie group whose relations to the
Taliban are somewhat questionable and
you know any kind of settlement like
this you've got to bring everybody on
board or you still got a serious
security and else we have criminal
groups that are also active and bring
back some wood well is that Robert Reid
has listed a number of accomplishments
on the part of the mission and kerinci
that more or less confirmed that yes the
mission is more widely perceived in a
positive light in Afghanistan but if you
do polls ironically speak if you do
polls in countries like the US or in
Germany on the mission in Afghanistan
many people are very critical they're
saying get our troops out 3,000 foreign
troops have already been killed
throughout this mission do you think the
leaders the Western leaders have not
been sufficiently able to explain the
mission to their own people and perhaps
even the success that came with it I
guess it was also the kind of
expectation that was raised to a certain
level and the goalposts will change all
the time you know we are doing we're
going to defeat Al Qaeda oh and we are
going to do State Building aldermen in
10 years time are going to be going to
schools work and they will not be
wearing work as and so on so forth and
that's I guess the problem and the
people here the you're extremely
confused but if you look at the polls in
Afghanistan the support for the mission
the support for our state is still above
seventy eighty percent you know support
for Taliban for example is six
centene our best so it is basically
looking from two different very
different perspectives in the West you
have different expectations because
killing of 3,000 people is too much for
you but in our country as you said I
mean we've been we are used in the past
we have we've had even more casualties
so basically this is the for us a good
mission may be outside the bigwigs
especially they they are now pains to
explain to people it's a good one but
they don't get it and on the question of
different groups of insurgency Pakistan
is the key Pakistan is the problem but
the problem impacts on is that its army
though the leadership the kind of
british-trained leadership is claiming
that they are in control but they are
not the army itself has been hijacked by
al-qaeda and there are forces in
Pakistan that the eventual collapse of
the Pakistani state within some years is
imminent to me at least observing facts
on their nuclear arsenal is going to be
a huge problem for for everyone
especially neighboring countries because
if they go straight and you don't know
what's going to happen so i guess the
focus should be to basically put paxton
in the limelight and force them not for
some but at least pressure them into
cracking down on those forces in Robert
Reed are you positive about the future
of Afghanistan post-2014 you know yes
surely yes and no shortly I wouldn't
invest any money there I wouldn't
recommend that anyone pull up stakes and
live there I don't think collapse is
inevitable though Colleen Sheila I would
invest money there I would live to it
and I have great faith in the people of
Afghanistan to make the best of the
situation and I think they are much
stronger and much better than we think
they are here so I have hope well I
thought both Robert reading how he left
hope do you have hope for the future of
your country what's your take we've been
at NT estate since 1809 so we are going
to need the money a lot of sustained
upstate basically if the money is there
then
I'm very positive that this country is
going to make the strides like in
cricket and football very good well on
that positive notes this country of
Afghanistan certainly has gone through
some hardship not only through the past
12 years but through some 300 years and
we will of course continue to monitor
the situation there and follow the
events they're very closely for now I
want to thank my guests for their
incredible insight into this very
complex country I want to thank you out
there for tuning in and looking forward
to seeing you again next week for a new
edition of quadriga
you